[Music]
ten thousand dollars now on the table
for any information that will help
figure out the name of a murder victim
the fbi metro police are still trying to
figure out who the boy is
who was found dead on a trail in
mountain springs joe moeller
live at metro headquarters with the very
latest on the investigation
joe oh brian it's been nearly a week and
we still do not know who this boy
is earlier today metro held a press
conference here explaining this is the
first part of this investigation now
they're releasing new photos
hoping they will help figure out who
exactly this boy is
we believe the age is going to be 8 to
10 years of age
these new digitally enhanced photos may
be the key in finding out the name of
this boy
that captures the gap in the child's
teeth we feel it captures his weight a
week has passed a detective still do not
know who he is or where he is from
for now his name is john little zion doe
after he was found murdered on the
little zion trail near mountain springs
friday may 28th
the boy is 4 foot 11 and 123 pounds
we're currently offering award of up to
10 thousand dollars
for information leading to the
identification
of john little zion doe the fbi is now
helping metro get the word out about
this case
this child has a right to be referred to
by his given name he's someone's son
someone's grandson and he deserves law
enforcement's commitment to solving this
case
hundreds of tips from around the country
have come in but nothing leading to a
name
they are working with a number of
agencies border patrol and even ccsd
we're counting on the public to help us
with his identification
they are also looking for people who may
have seen something unusual on state
route 160 between las vegas and pahrump
on friday may 28th
from midnight to 7 a.m any tip
regardless of how small
we are following up on
back out here live detectives say they
are trying to get people to share those
photos as much as possible once they
figure out who this child is
the homicide investigation part of this
case will start reporting live outside
the metro headquarters joe mullen eight
news now